Tyler is with us in Nevada hi Skyler
welcome to Dave Ramsey show hi thank you
for taking my call sure what's up so I
just have a question I know before I
even start I'm gonna change my
withholdings for my taxes but as of now
we are planning on getting a pretty big
refund back okay and my question is
should I pay that all weird babies up to
you towards all of my debt or should I
say that and my only concern is that my
husband's isn't as intense as I am so
I'm worried that we're going to pay it
off and then get right back into it
I can't fix that part my plan does not
address you going back into it
my plan addresses the idea that you're
going to change your life and never go
back there is there is no there is no
there is no sobriety program a rehab
program that accounts for you
occasionally still getting drunk agreed
that's the problem okay there's no such
thing this is behavior transformation
it's a decision I'm not gonna live like
that anymore and you have to decide I'm
not going to live like that anymore and
and the two of you have to decide now it
could be that you're just like me you're
like the super nerd you're the intense
one that loves the numbers and gets
after and he's just like okay I'll go
along but and you're kind of wished he'd
be a little bit more on fire maybe
you're not as concerned with him
dragging both of you off the wagon into
the road again but but if that's gonna
happen that's a different issue
that's a marriage issue and that's a
your husband issue and those kinds of
things that's not an issue of what to do
with your tax refund the tax reform just
exposes that you need to address the
other stuff yeah definitely yeah so get
comfortable you know the way I write
frame it would be this I would just sit
down with Sharon if it was at my house
and just go okay I've kind of been going
along with your lukewarm response to
this and I and I get it that you're not
as on fire as I am I get it that I'm a
super nerd I get it that I'm the
spreadsheet Queen I get it that you grow
your eyes a little bit when I say
MZ but you're going along with it I get
it and I was okay with you just going
along with it until I put this tax
refund on there and now it makes me
think you're gonna drag us off the wagon
later convince me you're not gonna do
that
and there'll be a way to start a cool
conversation maybe a fight but a good
conversation yeah and we've been there
many times I've had him listen to you a
few times and he's on board but he's
just not in thousand tenses I am yeah
well that's true at my house I'm intense
and Sharon is enjoying the fruits of it
I mean you know she's um she believes in
what we teach and she lives what we
teach and she doesn't do it with me
commanding or demanding that she do so
she actually believes that she rolls her
eyes when our friends do stupid stuff
you know all that kind of stuff so she's
on board but she's never gonna be as
wired up as I am and that might just be
all you're dealing with you know I mean
because the difference in the nerd and
the free spirit in the marriage is
substantially different you know what's
interesting is it Rachel cruises house
is that way Winston is more like me and
you he's the one that's deaf on this
stuff and Rachel's like you know lives
for experiences and so you know she but
she talks about that openly I mean it's
not like she's hit but critical in her
teachings or something but it's pretty
dramatic so you know you kind of
identify the differences of the two of
you in your marriage and you just say
hey that's the part of the fun of the
process so hey thank you for the call